we begin this half-hour with the
wrongful conviction of a teenager that
led to decades behind bars the reversal
now has the Kansas State Attorney
re-examining the case along with
possible problems in about a dozen other
convictions Dean Reynolds takes a look
when Lamont McIntyre was exonerated last
October in a double murder case he
walked out of a Kansas prison with a
clean record but not a dime to his name
you lost 23 years of your life now the
state is offering you nothing
I think it's unjust but me being angry
about is not going to change it Kansas
is one of 18 states that offer wrongly
convicted prisoners no compensation at
all upon their release sounds almost
vengeful or neglectful at the very it
for the in the nicest way of looking at
it Trisha Bushnell of the Innocence
Project worked to win McIntyre's release
she says McIntyre has other reasons to
be angry in this case we have a perfect
storm for example at his trial in 1994
when he was 17 there was no physical
evidence or motive presented worse
according to McIntyre's current lawyers
the lead police detective Roger Galoob
ski built the case by threatening
witnesses Bushnell says the fallout may
impact other potential exonerations we
have about a dozen people who had
already applied these are people behind
bars now that's right a dozen cases
connected to this detective that's right
detective gallupi has since retired and
says he did nothing wrong
it was the same places but mark Dupree
who became the state's attorney a year
ago has asked the Kansas Bureau of
Investigation to review the detectives
conduct if my office receives that
information and there's probable cause
to charge mr. deluca it will happen
McIntyre got a pretty raw deal he did
and the only thing that we can do is is
push forward nice to relax the hair
which is exactly what Lamont McIntyre
now studying to be a barber is do
we don't want to spend the rest of my
life being happy I want to I don't want
to be bitter that's taken away from me I
don't have no more time of year for CBS
this morning Saturday Dean Reynolds
Kansas City Kansas it's a real test of
the human spirit it sure is sure is
we're glad Lamont and I can't iris able
to turn the page